he's on a network television program
he's got a new book out called everyone
can be a ninja find your inner warrior
and achieve your dreams former NFL
player and an NFL Network fantasy live
analyst and co-host and better yet an
even better person as he's on the board
of the awesome wah foundation the
Michael J Fox foundation and a celebrity
ambassador for Red Nose Day he is none
other than Akbar Bashaw producer I'm
happy to be here giving I love having
your man yeah thank you so much yeah
again I I tell the story almost every
time I'll tell it again I met you for
the first time with your brother yep
with Kabir 2004 on the NFL Network set
yeah you were what you were you in and
that was my second year in the NFL okay
yeah I just grown up my hair I thought I
was cool just pierced my ear yeah I
thought so man I'm I'm bling-blinging it
in the whole night I'll never forget
that and you kid Norton yeah and and
Julia and then it was you and your
brother could be her yes and it was the
Baja BIA millas versus the NFL Network
analyst yeah they came a family feud
yeah and I guess that was that your
first ever
I guess game or reality show this game
first time on a major you know TV
network that was the whole thing and I
still remember how gracious you were he
gave us a tour of the control room nice
to have the picture of miles I still I
still have that picture of miles yeah
and I also remember where you were
realizing fast that your NFL playing
career would not need to lead to
something else yeah and you were trying
to figure out what that was and how to
go ahead and make that transition in the
transition you've made is been
remarkable and second to none I mean how
did how was that process for you well I
will tell you it was extremely tough I
mean there's this transition period that
you go through where I call it an
identity crisis you've been identified
for so long as an athlete and when
people see you your size suggest to
other people that oh you must be an
athlete you should still be playing why
aren't you playing and so there's that
part where you're trying to figure out
who you are because I truly believe that
the hardest person to know is yourself
because you have denial you have all
these other things expectations of other
people and once you kind of get through
all of that you kind of figure out who
you
or what you are what you want to do and
so for me it took me a while but there
was this aha moment that I had where I
was just tired of being identified as a
former athlete I wanted to kind of
redefine that but I also new to getting
into this business would be hard for me
because I didn't have the career like my
brother I was very much a journeyman
had two career sacks so that doesn't
suggest that that would turn around into
a TV career and I just remember saying
you know what I'm gonna take the
backdoor approach and the backdoor
approach was going to a place where I
had a little bit more equity which was
San Diego spent one year with the
Chargers played for the Aztecs and so I
went to the local NBC affiliate there
and said hey I'd do the Aztec pregame
and postgame show and the Chargers
postgame show for free they looked at me
to go what for free go yeah I'll do it
for free I did that for two years to
learn the skill set for nothing for
nothing that was all inspired by an
interview that I had with ESPN where I
met with al Jaffe and Fred Brown I know
yeah I know al is for sure that was the
one who called me and on my job at K RCR
TV the local a toilet in red in
California to say that he'd seen my tape
and he wanted to interview me and I
almost dropped an MF bomb on him because
I thought it was it like a joke yeah cuz
like an agent had called me few minutes
before at my desk and reading to say
that he had seen my tape and wanted to
see more tape and I called my brother
Jeff and said hey he'll never guess the
phone call I just got and told him and I
thought he told one of my friends call
rich right now because he is totally
gonna buy this hook line and show oh wow
I almost M effed literally al Jeffy who
is the guy who you needed to hear from
you know right absolutely she's got an
interview with I had an interview with
him and Fred Brown and long story short
it was like hey look what makes you any
different from any of these other guys
they said that to you yeah I said what
makes you need to and that was like kind
of like taking back when I was like I'm
trying to figure out and I remember the
the dumbest thing I ever said in that
interview I talked about it in my book I
said well I'm just like Stuart Scott
first off feels a damn lie
is that what you said I said that and
that ended the interview they were
gracious they gave me a tour of the
facility and he said to me the last
words that they said to me and says hey
you know what you need to do you need to
go out there you need to get some tape
you don't have any tape you don't have a
chance and I didn't take that they
weren't like making fun of me or and
insulting me like the truth was I
thought hey I just got done in the NFL
you know I can make this broadcasting
thing I got a degree in it yeah thinking
I could do it no no you ever get a
chance to tell that story to Stuart
Akbar no never you never did never he
would have gotten such a big kick yeah
Akbar Bobby amela here Rich Eisen show
American Ninja Warrior and we'll talk
about your book in a second a little bit
more you are like Stuart in a way that
that you are when you we see you on
television your that's who I'm seeing
right out the guy who is off the air is
the guy that I'm seeing on the air and
Stuart you know so many people that's an
act I mean the way that he would say his
phrases or drop music lyrics into his
phrasing oh gee that will and that was
him I mean that was literally him you
know the and and it's so cool because in
that interview I remember them saying
hey look we have our own Stuart Scott so
we don't need we know we have our we
have Stuart Scott we don't need another
Stuart Scott right and I remember going
back and I talked to one of my mentors
and he said suggested I take acting
classes and acting classes not to become
the next Denzel Washington but become a
better version of me and get to be more
of me and what I realize is that I'm a
goofy silly nerdy dude and that's just
who I am and one of the things that
inspired me growing up was wrestling and
so a lot of my commentary is inspired by
wrestling I love physiology I love
anatomy and so I bring a lot s oh so you
hear crazy muscles being named on there
and you'll see here some of the colorful
stuff but it's a combination of what I
grew up listening to the stuart scott
and WWE no wonder you and Nnamdi awesome
all get along yes I know we're different
we're just different we weren't the
traditional you know NFL guys you know
right yeah we travel the world we've
been to over 40 countries yet somehow
yeah we're just different well it's
interesting how you also hear indraft
conversations that when when there are
guys who have stuff other than football
they're like well see really focused
it's intimidating to the owners and I
hate it I really hate like miles Garrett
is that way he's you know very artistic
and you know sometime now honestly he's
such a physical presence and so
sometimes they'll overlook that but if
you don't have the physical presence of
a Myles Garrett then they go well maybe
he's not it's just like you should I
think owners change they should
encourage players to be more of
themselves and that you're just not
one-dimensional you want a player that
is multi-dimensional because it allows
him to be even better on the field but
when you lock a person in because of
fear that their other interests may take
over I think you're losing who that
person is that person becomes you know
dissatisfied not you know you know you
know you want that person to feel home I
couldn't agree with you more Akbar
because the way I look at it is if you
as a player are viewing life in a way
that footballs are just part of it it
has more to it why wouldn't you bring
that mindset to the game itself right
why wouldn't you say well okay just like
you said you had two career sacks
there's one way to get to the
quarterback that I think I know of maybe
there's other ways maybe there's other
ways to look at this maybe there's a
larger world view that you could bring
to the sport itself to your game if
football is all about control it's all
about control sport man yeah there's a
ton of that you know and and that's
what's neat about in this book everyone
can be a ninja find your inner warrior
and achieve your dreams with Akbar Basha
be a Milla right here on the Rich Eisen
show do you remember the two sacks first
one was against Dante Culpepper
okay thick died yeah and very hard to
take down their walls against Drew
Bledsoe who was again another thick died
guy so a little bit more escape ability
yes Dante was yeah Dante was what was
this post knee injury Dante oh no this
is pre this is previous Dante pre in
fact I was so out of it it was Warren
Sapp who looked to me say oh you know
Jerry
cuz I just came off without it you know
I was just kind of like in a daze like
man I'm starting and that I came off the
sideline now remember Ted washing tables
to the left worn samples to the right
[Music]
it's Culpepper
I guess Dante grossie was on the field
then I have that picture in my home on
my wall and a person's in the back
looking back is up taking down Culpepper
yeah Nate's another guy without the
championships or Pro Bowl yeah racked up
that's done an incredible job right he
does personality swagged out as heck oh
heck yeah he really is let's talk a
little bit of American Ninja Warrior
that again is gonna be on again tonight
when when you who walks you through the
course how does that work well it used
to be that they have a diagram and that
they send out yeah I used to study it I
mean just till I was nauseous and I
wanted to know every angle the fu and an
email you get it and of course we got to
keep it in guarded so none of the ninjas
hack into our site and and then try to
figure out you know how to you know how
to prepare for it because they don't get
a chance to see it until they step on
the course and what I realize is that it
kind of took away from the analysis so
now I wait until the day of until I see
the obstacles so I'm just as enamored by
the obstacles as the competitors are so
the authentic reactions are real on TV
so I walk through them like who that
just like I heard you earlier like I'm
like who designed this what is the name
of this again how does this work oh no
nobody's ever getting through this and
so when I see somebody get through it
I'm genuinely surprised because I'm like
this is ridiculous it's ridiculous I
mean I ran it last year for the first
time and I can tell you I'm glad like
it's like me jumping out of a plane I
did it once I survived I've never have
to do it again when people ask me about
it that's like oh I ran the course
already it's on YouTube you can go
google it YouTube it cuz I'll never do
it again because it's that difficult
it's really that challenge did you get
through oh heck yeah I got through it oh
yeah miles it I was nervous that I was
more nervous than ever ever was in my
life in any football game college game
because I say man
I could lose my cred here if I go down
how could I tell the next ninja that
they need to do this and then I guess
I'm that guy I'm the height guy that
tell you what you need to do on the
course and if I go down like that was
pressure riches that was pressure it's
more pressure than you run in the for
more pressure than 40 stepping out of my
own wheelhouse by doing that even though
I have done it now right 15 years in a
row 15 years yeah it's coming up 15
years you've gotten faster huh it's all
right I'm used to it
one of the other five nine four five
nine four is you're joking right oh
excuse me yeah
try try running doing try doing your
Ninja Warrior course in a suit okay I'm
running in a suit man parachute behind
and I'm also not physically get first
off I've been watching you since I was
at least in when I first got cable which
was in college okay so I know you rich
so I know no pun intended there so I
know you can afford the lycra suits with
the stretchy material the stretchy
material this year I got the sweat sweat
tailor gave me a suit this year that's
the first time the otherwise it was like
full-on yeah a little bit stretchy right
so I don't want to hear the excuses in a
suit well I'm saying that you know i've
gotten snoop once gave me and that's the
name drop okay said take off the the
jacket yep and wear a bow tie because
he's trying to make me aerodynamically
sound yeah and I just won't do it that's
not my uniform my uniform is the suit ah
yes it's suit and tie it's what I do if
you wanna hate on me on this sort of
thing we can put up our
respective first allow it since you're
my guest I am the host I'm more than
happy you do know I've played linebacker
so I'd drop back into coverage back to
the coverage to come off the line real
quick I do love that you said that you
used to you know bring your I guess if
you will player mentality you need to
prepare yeah that you you wanted to know
the course cold before walking in and
now you are several years into it like
I'm just gonna read and react to this
thing right comfortable enough to do
that because that is the natural I want
to hear your natural reaction but you're
saying these ninjas aren't given even a
heads up no they just they just know
that running up the wall is yes now it
used to be there's two staple the
beginning obstacle right and then and in
the end but now we've changed up the
front last year we had the archer steps
this year we have the shrinking steps so
even that they didn't know that until
they first got there but then all the
obstacles in between so what we do is
sometimes we'll set up obstacles
especially when we're out in public yeah
we'll actually put out dummy obstacles
until the night of because some of the
ninjas will get hotel rooms and they'll
come on oh yeah you guys you think the
NFL's okay oh we got ninja gates to go
out there and they'll take binoculars
I'm not playing around
yeah we've had ninjas we've seen ninjas
spy and go recreate it that that same
day where they get the material without
the specs they just think it works like
this I think it works like that and
they'll go try to duplicate what they
think they can so we've become a lot
smarter and savvy err in putting up
dummy obstacles so now how much you
warned them don't try this at home they
attempt to do it literally in their
hotels right oh yeah I mean and these
ninja gyms are popping up everywhere now
like I'm telling you it's just it's it's
caught fire for a good reason it's just
an incredible watch it's a lot of fun
like I told you my kids are so excited
that you were here on the show I tell
you that every time but it's good too
and now this book is well one of the
hardest things ever have to do I bet
what is it what did what did what does
this mean to you that you have you're
basically life story
right here in a book and try to let
folks know how to have their inner
warrior well you know to me it was a
personal project you know I had been
inspired it's been really like a lecture
hall for me hosting Ninja Warrior now
for the last eight years and watching
these ninjas kind of go through
obstacles but it made me kind of think
about my own personal life and just the
personal obstacles that I had to
overcome from growing up in South
Central Los Angeles to being an
undrafted free agent and then trying to
break into an industry you know that was
really set for guys with yellowjacket
playoffs and so on and so forth and I've
become very vulnerable talking about you
know my childhood with my mother being
an alcoholic then losing my mother in a
car accident but I also want to mentor
that with other stories from other
ninjas that I've been inspired by like
zach gowen who competed with one leg but
Allyson Felix Lindh in her story Nnamdi
Asomugha now San Felix people see the
gold medalists and how decorated an
athlete she is and they don't really
know her story and so she shares her
story I interview her for the book but
this is a book about overcoming
obstacles because we all have them a lot
of us aren't as transparent about the
personal obstacles because especially
now we kind of curate this life on
social media that we're all doing good
as Oprah would say we're living our best
life you know but you know truth is is
that you can live your best life and
still have obstacles that you that
you're overcoming that you've overcame
and part of it is just sharing the story
because that inspires someone else so
everyone can be a ninja is a book that
inspires people to overcome their
obstacles just like the show and you
know for me to know that I've written a
book that my kids can read when they get
older and they'll be able to kind of you
know have stories there was another
thing too my mom passed away I realized
that man I didn't really know my mom
outside of being mom and I didn't know
her personal story and what things and
obstacles she had to get through I'm
just thinking but she came into this
country in 1969 from Nigeria I can only
imagine the hardship she had to
acclimate to the American culture I was
able to get my father's story in here
like and stuff that blew my mind away
because I just
asked my dad I mean and that's some of
the things like how much of these
stories do we get out of our the people
who are even close to us my dad came to
this country with $500 in his pocket I
was just like and that's the equivalent
of it today 500 hours of equivalent
today's $500 I was just blown away with
you know just him sleeping on the couch
you know on the bus stop his very first
night in America I just never told me
that story you know fast forward 40
years later seven kids you know two kids
played in the NFL all of his kids you
know are doing well I mean that's a
that's a big deal it's amazing everyone
can be a ninja is in bookstores we're
all books are sold can I keep you for
one more set yeah talk about all the
fantasy stuff okay with that right
around the corner but when we come back
on the television side of things you
have locked a copy of everyone can be a
ninja inside of an obstacle box an
obstacle we're renaming the puzzle box
as an obstacle box okay and Chris
Brockman you are holding it right there
in the television only segment you will
attempt to open that up is that what
you're going to attempt to do how many
people live the have over 250 people
have tried you ha men Laila Ali just to
name some of them those are name drops
very good and I'm offering $1,000
Christie right now all right if you can
if you can open it you get $1,000 I'll
pay penalty or if you like cash I leave
it to your a venmo guy so in a minute is
that fine no three minutes I've taken
three minutes but he know you'll start
in a television only segment and then
you will try to finish it by the time we
get back with Akbar on the other side of
the radio break how does that sound
that's next right here on the Rich Eisen
share with Tyson Fury making his way to
our set all right Akbar watch out via
millas locked a copy of his book
everyone can be a ninja into his own you
made this huh yes I'm a physio designed
it an obstacle box yep all right Chris
you've got three minutes to open it up
you do it you get $1,000 okay here we go
look at Chris you guys have a
conversation
you going yeah that thing in the middle
Chris you want to move that up does it
move up it doesn't move nothing moves
it's gotta move and just remember and
you're familiar with the show the show
American Ninja Warrior is about you know
ninjas going through obstacles I just
told you that the book is about
overcoming obstacles and I thought how
fitting we put the book into an obstacle
box now this was inspired by my
five-week trip to Morocco I was in
Morocco and they loved puzzle boxes over
there maybe shove it together does it
push push something in Chris there's a
lot of time gone by on the side Chris
what are the thing on the side give it a
Mike give it a Mike pass it off passed
the baton though he's so great if he
just takes five seconds you said it can
be open in 15 15 seconds you designed it
of course you can open on but seriously
it's so simple like you just have to
take time and mess around with it well
you're only giving us three minutes
nobody's ever opened it oh no one's ever
opened it this is called the everyone
who's a little jealous has anyone gotten
as close as Mike he might be the first
one to figure out that quickly it's
taking people right at the last minute
to Mike Mike you're going somewhere a
beautiful mind like you're right there
come on Mike come on what about one of
those boys the top does it click off
it's not as it snap off okay don't let
the pressure of the thousand dollars of
the three minutes get to you but it's
really so simple it's right in front of
you oh my gosh all right TV's over but
keep going you got about another
a minute to go 45 seconds Wow it's
moving it's moving no no no no no don't
use force don't use force don't break
that that's as far as they can go
pull it lift pull it lift
no no sweetie nope there's no twisting
involved no twisting involved this
thing's moving no for lot it's no force
required no force required fifteen
seconds Mike no what is that not even
Commons gotten this close he's out of
time
Wow Brockman got his first crack at
opening up the puzzle no chance you
didn't move anything we're like and
adopted l/24 you're like yeah fat chance
and you he got as far as anybody's ever
gotten yeah I mean he was pretty close
and then he he panicked because he got
so close yeah he moved the book yeah
move it I hand it back to you sir for
future use but I love the try it would
not you pay me I want to figure if you
can open it up in three minutes
okay so in the few minutes we have left
with you are Bashaw p.m. Ella the first
player taken in a fantasy football draft
this year you get the first place
selection Barclay that's easy
you didn't stutter no I said the same
thing too yes a qualm bar I said the
same thing too he's so dynamic and I
think that obviously without dill not
being there I think O'Dell obviously
took a lot of you know opportunities
away from sake Wamba say Quan they're
gonna have to lean on him even more so
people would say that Odell created more
opportunities for say Quan because
there's somebody else that required the
defense's attention that's yeah and
that's why say Quan shouldn't be the
number one overall so that's great come
on what we witnessed and saw with our
own eyes I mean his ability to create
stuff in space
his ability to extend plays it's just
it's just too obvious Mike my only fear
is is that they're going to go to them
maybe too much because they're gonna try
to compensate for the loss of production
that they had in an Old Ale Beckham
junior and thinking oh say Kwan can do
it is this like when you have a guy
who's so telling it all this person can
handle it and you kind of put them you
put too much on to their plate and then
you kind of elevate them into the
position of maybe not being as effective
and fantasy wise now I know you've been
a co-host of NFL fantasy life man this
is coming up on your seventh year yeah
right here yeah seven years since you
first started year eight season there so
what is your philosophy on taking a wide
receiver in the first round then you
know I'm a running back guy just because
of all um-- you start looking at volume
but I mean there are certain players
who've kind of you know bug debt a guy
that I would probably feel comfortable
it's hard to say it's a first overall
but if I wanted to be a little risky
J Hopkins I mean he's in the same system
he's got the same you know the same you
know nucleus of people around him right
into playmakers right but a person like
an Odell Beckham I think people need to
be cautious of that why because he's in
a new system yes I know there's a lot of
buzz around cleaver right now I'm
excited about cleavage too and I think
people can be over reactive because
you've got the Nick Chubb and you've got
the Landry and he's back with his boy
and all this other stuff but yeah I
don't know Freddie kitchens like that do
you I don't know him like that that's
not one of my homies I mean and I'm not
saying I'm against him but I just don't
know what he brings to the league I
don't know how all of that comes
together and then you know this Baker
Mayfield I've saw some of his commentary
and a lot of it seems a little fake like
fake leadership like I got to present
myself like that you have to mature into
that you can't just come out your
teammate like that you got a maturing
today April 14th he just turned 24 I
understand that but but he's also
changing a culture and he's also winning
his own stamp Baker Mayfield is this the
Cleveland Browns where everybody thinks
that they're the sad-sack they're the
trapdoor they're the team that always
stinks that the team that has a coach
that always stinks
the whole team stays at French I see
just saying and he's planting a flag
right there in the middle saying not
anymore and you might sit here see it
and earn that right you can't plant it
he has to grow it there's a difference
because you planting that's by force you
can't do it by force and I think that's
been the problem with the Cleveland
Browns again all these people that say
I'm gonna change it right now you have
to grow it from the ground up and all
the stuff that he's got to manage all of
that
leave that to management and the
coaching staff to do all the
personalities with Landry and Odell and
all that stuff what about want us to
grow grow with it so we've got two
minutes left so what if the fact that
we're in the 21st century this time that
you don't talk about the coach after
he's left and me and you don't talk
about another players business we're on
your ass directly about that other
players rightness that's 20 century
we're in the 21st century Baker Mayfield
is the 21st century quarterback who if
he's asked a direct question about some
guy on his team who everybody thinks is
a distraction he's like he's not it's
riding the hype rich he's riding the hot
because let him have a bad season you
think he's gonna have that same
about 21st century confidence no he's
not gonna have that so all the hype I
got a little bit of leeway the minute
his season turned sour all of a sudden
is just as like well I'll talk well I
gotta talk to a coach about that and he
becomes more humbled just take that same
approach and be consistent don't have to
force it it's just when I watch it I
just like that feels forced hey come on
I'm not buying it and I don't have
anything against Baker Mayfield I just
don't like the whole fake I'm a leader
now I'm a leader because the second year
we got a lot of hype coming on Wow real
talk about fakeness just bled into our
fantasy conversation I'm sorry yeah rock
words here for that I'm here for it for
sure yeah even though that's the way you
act in your daily life yep that's 100%
true how many of these quarterbacks have
we seen blow up in their first year and
then blow up in their second season I
mean two different blow ups blow up and
implode everyone can be a ninja find
your inner warrior and achieve your
dreams unless you're Baker Mayfield by
[Laughter]
just God by like that you can't plant
you got to grow it yeah I like it
Chris brought when you have a news
update check on our poll question and
Tyson Fury stops by the Rich Eisen show
studio in our number three great to see
you sir thank you so much on it that's
Akbar watched the latest edition of
American Ninja Warrior tonight on NBC
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app